so the bet is a hundred push-ups for a
hundred dollars i'm like out of breath i
feel like i ran my like ears are ringing
i'm shaking right now i thought that i
was gonna be able to do that with some
difficulty my arms are safe
sam and i will still be working on stuff
but we also need to coordinate everybody
run the teams work on bigger projects
you know there's just there's a lot of
work for us to do so to alleviate that
clinton and adrian have joined the team
they're going to be working intently on
corridor videos much like how carmichael
and nick are focused on the seven eco
channel but here's the challenge the
biggest challenge of all is that we need
to be consistent on the corridor channel
establish what it is when you're
watching a corridor video clinton are
you in the game the game no he's not in
the game game of life wait wait wait
wait wait wait everyone stop is this
good thing is it a stupid game it's a
stupid game
first of all don't listen to anything
nico says because he's not in the game
so he's not allowed to talk about the
game so whatever he says disregard all
you need to know about the game is that
it's the best game you're gonna ever
have with your friends once you're in
you're in for life the game's only on
when the camera's on you can either
choose to agree or disagree
that's it you don't get the rules
everybody was saying everybody know sam
and nico hold on hold on adrian get in
there right now i don't know adrian's in
adrian's head let me think
it's not gonna impact anything it is a
trust exercise but there is a real game
you do is 10 push-ups don't tell him
anymore man you're in i love push-ups
all right keep things up here with a
corridor like what is corridor it's
about building audiences we need that
consistency for the channel video games
are the biggest influence on my
filmmaking not films in fact movies in
general if you try to make an internet
video like you make a movie you're going
to fail and you're not going to have a
good video the way you tell stories in
the cinema it's very different the way
you tell stories on your phone or your
computer screen we need to be more
consistent we need to really define what
it is to make a corridor video what is
corridor
what can the videos be we can it can be
whatever we want it to be but if we're
gonna if we're going to continue from
for what has been successful in the past
that is technically the gaming space
we're not cinema but the thing is visual
effects that are things we've never seen
before still work really well if it's
not concept based and it's not in the
gaming space those are already such
incredibly ambiguous topics is there
room for more exceptions yes but only
when the frequency or the volume of
those concept based and gaming based
pieces is able to overshadow the
exceptions narratives are tricky and i
think to tell narratives or tell stories
in the online space
you need to construct them in a certain
way that's a little bit different than
like television and short film like that
kind of stuff like the only word on
narratives i have is narratives
sometimes end up as a replacement for
content i hate to keep bragging on the
zombie versus matador video but in that
video the narrative takes up the space
in which a cool action scene should be
filling that's the problem with that
video a weak narrative is ends up being
a filler for what should be like the
actual promise of the premise and and
that's what frequently happens it's like
you're like oh it's a funny video where
a guy's cutting a zombie and they're
like cool page three it starts like
don't let the narrative get in the way
of the concept you're trying to to
communicate it's time to talk about this
everyone's been asking me what happened
to the 16 000 push-ups i owed and
whether or not i paid my debt to society
we came into a clemency agreement i had
to do a hundred push-ups a day until the
end of the year
here's what here's what
there's no way that i could have done
them all i didn't do it all i'm sorry i
did it for like two weeks and my arms
were so
sore because there was no recovery time
i hope this doesn't mean that you look
less upon me
i hope that you can understand the
trouble that i felt in in in coming to a
conclusion on this whose headphones are
these because it used to not the they
were the ones that were on my desk
they're not yours they're not my
personal ones oh who's watching
mine dude
that was so easy
oh yeah
that's my personal one
dude we build credit i feel like you can
only build credit if it's in front of a
witness who's also in the game you gotta
bust a hundred push-ups in one go hold
on i bet you hundred bucks you can't a
hundred dollars
every month a very special dream team of
our patrons goes above and beyond to
help us make videos and every month we
like to take a second to thank them each
individually so thank you remco cats
richard blackburn brian antosik james
bailey glitch cube mike plinsky colin
heaton erlich kemken taylor dunbar sohak
lai rory richard linder and of course
gary delft welcome to the club if you
guys are interested in being part of the
dream team or just helping us out with a
buck or two on patreon it goes to making
these videos so check out patreon.com
corridor digital patreon.com corridor
digital so the bet is a hundred push-ups
for a hundred dollars upon the phone
so i can rest you can you can rest okay
your knees down
down yeah
that if you are able to do it you're
getting a credit i got a credit here you
guys gotta get that credit
[Music]
52.
jake's done
ever supposed to be going backwards
let's do jake's dad also you said don't
you dare come over here
or the word wait
60 83 83 it it you can do this
you can do it adrian
are you really gonna do it
i'm trying
89
nine
keep the form aren't you supposed to
have your elbows back so you don't hit
your shoulders while doing push-ups
seven
your specific bet
six establish four before that okay 90
degree angles
i'll get the five
four
don't you give up now you don't you
three
one two two
get it son is it one more get it one
last
[Applause]
one my arms are shaking
adrian you won yourself a game of life i
got one credit
i thought that i was gonna be able to do
that with some difficulty and i got to
30. oh there's no way and then i got to
i got to 54 and i realized that if i
really pushed i could probably get to
70. but knowing that i'd still be 30
short i just gave up respect for
everyone here shaking right now man that
was hard
that was not easy i'm like out of breath
i feel like i ran my like ears are
ringing we know
that forms weren't perfect in what we
just did so please don't make a comment
on it when i was trying to do my debt
people were commenting seriously
concerned for my future health here's
how here's what i learned you do them
like this keep your elbows in
yep okay
yep
nico guy who's not in the game
just standing there commenting
as teddy roosevelt once said credit
doesn't belong to the critic but to the
man in the arena
you want fives or ones jake
respect oh
honesty friendship
wow honesty friendship
honor
when sam pays me that ten dollars he
owes me i wasn't going to give it back
to him clint's clearly a better man than
i am no comment
so we've been making videos on the
corridor channel for years and we've
been making videos on the sam and nico
channel for years this year in an effort
to kind of make everything make more
sense for everyone out there we are
renaming the saminiko channel to the
corridor crew because that's
who we are and actually that's who these
videos follow it's the people who make
these videos on the quarter channel and
so even though the name sam and nico is
going away
we are most certainly not and set your
set your watches well actually hold on
we don't know exactly when it's going to
change we're still working on things but
this is more of a warning even though
things might change visually or
graphically just a little bit there the
content is going to say absolutely the
same no actually it's actually going to
get better
trust me